Уранці 30 липня усіх кандидатів у президенти Білорусі, окрім Лукашенка,
терміново викликали до Центрвиборчкому на розмову.
Приводом стала заява офіційного Мінська про затримання напередодні
бойовиків з іноземної приватної військової організації.
Нам сказали, що в країні є 170 бойовиків
з навичками підривної та снайперської діяльності.
Люди дають різні свідчення.
Декотрі з них кажуть напряму: "Ми приїхали робити революцію".
Білоруські державні ЗМІ повідомляють, що вночі з 28 на 29 липня
у санаторії під Мінськом начебто затримали
33-х бойовиків із так званої "ЧВК Ваґнера".
Група звернула на себе увагу типовим одягом у стилі "мілітарі"
та нетиповою для туристів поведінкою.
У розпорядженні інформагентства БЕЛТА опинився начебто
повний список затриманих з прізвищами і датами народження.
Усі затримані нібито громадяни Росії,
чотирнадцять з них згадуються в українській базі "Миротворець"
як учасники бойових дій на Донбасі.
Як стверджують державні ЗМІ із посиланням на білоруські правоохоронні органи,
загалом до Білорусі прибули понад 200 бойовиків -
"для дестабілізації обстановки у період виборчої кампанії".
Президент Білорусі Олександр Лукашенко
сам зробив різку заяву з приводу гучного затримання:
Я дивлюся на реакцію росіян.
Вони вже виправдовуються, кажуть, що ледь не ми самі їх завезли.
Ну, треба ж якось виправдати свої брудні наміри.
Тому дуже просив би, щоб у цій ситуації та з цим фактом
все було якомога відверто і чесно.
Варто відзначити, що лише кілька днів тому Лукашенко застеріг
про можливу відправку до Білорусі бандитів, які є фаховими військовими.
Усякі війни тепер починаються з вуличних протестів,
демонстрацій, потім майдани.
На Майдани у нас малувато "майданутих",
їх підтягнуть зі сторони.
Це професійні військові, бандити.
Їх спеціально готують. В основному в межах "ЧВК" по всьому світі.
І  заробляють великі гроші на провокаціях у тих чи інших державах.
За наслідками інциденту, мінське МЗС викликало
для консультацій послів Росії та України.
Служба безпеки України відстежує діяльність "ЧВК Вагнер",
незалежно від географічного розташування - у Сирії, Судані або Білорусі.
Адже вважає, що її найманці причетні до бойових дій на Донбасі.
Зокрема до штурму донецького аеропорту та боях за Дебальцеве.
На сьогодні нам відомо більше двох тисяч прізвищ
конкретних імен бійців приватної військової компанії Вагнера.
Про них ми розповіли не тільки в Україні.
Про них ми розповідаємо і нашим партнерам.
Це приватна військова компанія, яка працює
на російське політичне керівництво.
Вони мають на озброєнні важку техніку і зброю
і причетні до найрезонансніших злочинів як на території України,
так і на території Сирії та інших держав. І ми переконані,
що якщо прийде час і Росія захоче розв'язати десь новий конфлікт,
то ці "зелені чоловічки" будуть саме звідти."
За даними СБУ, насправді це псевдоприватний підрозділ.
Існує версія, що "вагнерівців" через приховані статті витрат
опосередковано фінансує міністерство оборони Росії
та бізнесмен Євген Пригожин, наближений до президента Росії
Володимира Путіна, ще відомий як "кухар Путіна".
Чому вагнерівці були у Білорусі?
Експерти не виключають, що інцидент узагалі міг бути сфабрикований спецслужбами.
Адже Лукашенку як ніколи потрібні надзвичайні заходи
для перемоги на президентських виборах.
Йому довіряють дедалі менше білорусів.
Насамперед присутній аспект залякування.
Оскільки білоруська влада регулярно для того, щоб збити протестні настрої
використовує такого роду загрози.
Це було у 2006-му з пацюками у водопроводі,
це було у 2017-му зі справою "білого легіону"
і це було в інші роки, коли були різні сумнівні терористичні атаки,
коли хапали людей, не причетних, як з'ясувалось потім, до цих справ.
Це створюється для нагнітання страху і для збиття цих протестних настроїв,
аби люди боялися виходити на майдани.
СБУ звернулася до Білорусі із запитом про екстрадицію затриманих 33 осіб
через імовірно скоєні ними військові злочини
на території Донеччини та Луганщини.